i i would never ever want to be that
person that says
i've seen everyone there is to see
i never want to be that person i will
always be like there's more
i'll find more
where did they all begin for you how did
you get into casting
oh god um i was a bit of a lost soul at
16 you know gcses and all that and
everyone seemed to have a very clear
idea of what it is that they wanted to
do
i don't know who at 16 knows what their
big life choice is going to be i
certainly didn't so i went and did
b-tech performing arts because all my
mates were doing it and i just wanted
the social life but anytime they'd say
oh lauren will you get up and do this
like oh no i don't want to do that
please i don't want to sing i'm going to
do this but i knew i wanted to be
involved in the arts and in this
industry
so i finished college
still very lost to the gap year still
lost and then did a
an undergraduate course in arts
management
which i really didn't enjoy it was very
much geared towards the visual arts but
in the final year we had a module that
was work placement
so i went back to um
the state
the stagecoach the um drama school that
i went to as child on a sunday and they
had started
a management company alongside for the
children who were part of the school
and i went for the summer to be an agent
there or nathan's assistant
and really enjoyed it and as i was
getting into it i realized i was talking
to casting offices all day and sort of
seeing getting a glimpse into their
world they would be doing lists and they
would be looking for actors for the
shows that they were doing
and just thought as much as i enjoyed it
i thought i might be on the wrong side
so when i finished uni i stayed with the
agency for a little bit and then after
about a year
i made the leap into casting and um
sent a letter to anyone who would have
it and i had one response from kate dowd
who is a lovely american casting
director based here who gave me an
internship and i worked on brad pitt's
film world war z that's my first job
which absolutely blew my mind
and then from there i did about eight
months and then
an agent recommended me to nina who was
looking for an assistant and i went
there for six years
what initially drew you to casting then
i didn't realize until i got into it
that i'd always always sort of
immediately been doing it like my
brother and i are massive musical
theater fans and we loved films growing
up and we would always recast the films
with our mates
like who would play that like who would
be uncle buck from the people that we
know
or in les mis
my brother'd be like i'll be valjean
like okay and i'll be like one of the
people in the pub
but who else from our mates would we
cast as the main roles and we were just
always intrigued by it
and i used to watch films
my brother would be outside playing
football and i would be sat in front of
the tv all the time and i would finish
like a vhs and i would rewind it
straight away and i'd watch it all
through again i suppose just looking for
different things to pick up and
i was always really keen to track actors
in different films and be like oh they
were this like that girl was in on the
back and she was also in sleepless in
seattle and i just sort of enjoyed
tracking people's
moves i suppose so yeah i suppose that's
why i got into it but i just i didn't
know how i didn't know how to penetrate
that world that seems so far to my reach
what's you makes a good script what what
you look for or what do you find
in a piece of writing where you're like
you know what i really want to be
involved in this what sticks out to you
i don't know i was never really
confident in my taste especially when it
comes to writing i have a very i mean i
loved it i have a very basic education
and you know in terms of like the
english language i don't excel in any
sort of writing myself so i was always
sort of fairly lacking in confidence
when it comes to analyzing the script
and
being assured in my own taste that is
this good is this not
and i used to send it to friends and say
like write to friends what do you think
of this is this any good and i think it
might have been sex ed where i read it
and thought
i don't care what anyone else thinks i
think this is brilliant it was funny i
could it was so moorish i would get
through
you know an episode in like 50 minutes
because i just couldn't put it down and
that for me is enough the same with like
chloe i just couldn't stop and i wanted
to know more
sometimes if i know it just feels a bit
hard to get through it's a bit of a slog
i know that maybe it's not the one for
me
let's talk a bit more about sex
education because
without a doubt it's one of the best tv
series come out i would say in the last
decade i think it's really shaped
how
young people can think of themselves and
they can see themselves in these
characters and you've been able to cast
these people properly plays such an
important role a lot of these actors had
never worked professionally before so
how did you find this amazing talent it
was just we met a lot a lot of people
and the great thing was we
we had no pressure to cast people who
were established who had a body of work
which was brilliant well i think we one
of
netflix uk sort of um original shows
so there was no pressure there which was
brilliant and we just made sure that we
met a lot of people who were within the
appropriate age bracket and um
yeah it was if we saw someone that we
saw was really special but not right we
remembered them for something else
because it was quite a big ensemble
um but it was just
yeah making sure that we kept a very
open mind and met a lot of people
and were confident in our taste and our
instincts and
knew who we wanted to push forward
really have you ever had an experience
where you've picked your cast members
they're all amazing individually and
then in rehearsals for some bizarre
reason the chemistry has just been off
between the actors has that ever
happened not yet because i'm very good
at my job
no but not yet but i'm sure i will but
that's because we're supposed to be
spending so much time putting these
people together
and making sure they have it before we
offer them the job
yeah yeah yeah do you have any casting
techniques then or exercises that you
use to
ensure that the chemistry is there
before you kind of sign the dotted line
with those actors we like to get them in
so when we get them into the room to do
the scenes we get them into like the
waiting area first whether it's an hour
or half an hour and they just certainly
chat and they meet one another there's
no worse thing than just staying in the
room okay
here's your love interest off you go i
mean it's so unnatural so we try to get
them checked in
uncomfortable with one another
um before they go in especially when
when we went on to season two and three
these characters had become so well
loved that actually some people came in
and was slightly star-struck so of
course that is immediately quite jarring
for someone to come in and have to
contend with so we just try to put
everyone at ease first and give them a
bit of time to
acclimatize maybe and how important is
it for you to
keep up these relationships i suppose
and keep them positive to bring these
same actors back at other projects that
you might be working on in the future
yeah it's really important um because
it's great to
have actors that you know
are really good and solid and reliable
and brilliant and it's great to help you
know guide their careers you know people
like alastair petry has an astonishing
career and always has but sex ed has
sort of elevated that to another level
which is brilliant and if i can help in
any way facilitate that but i'm
thrilled but it's also as nice as it is
to have
those relationships where you do
bring in the same people it's also
really nice to give
new people an opportunity which is the
balance that i'm trying to strike
some work in progress was the worst at
all of a casting director and ensuring
equal representation on screen
yeah i mean
we like i say we don't have we don't
hold that much power but if we i mean we
bang that drum and we can bang it and if
people are listening then it's great and
if people aren't then it's like you know
it's frustrating but we'll do all we can
to push forward
the fight full representation on
inclusivity and for us specifically as a
casting office we
always try to
seek out those from underrepresented
groups rather than wait for them to be
suggested because it's not necessarily
them with the theatrical agents and
stuff so we try to look further afield
and throw that net a little bit wider
whether that's going to social media or
just doing our own research
and trying to build on those databases
rather than being complacent thinking oh
well if they're out there they're
interested they'll be suggested so i
suppose it's that but we do try to
challenge
a lot of the time and say well what
about this role and could we open this
up and could and then you know present
what we tend to do is present it in a
sometimes in a visual way to say you
know what about changing this up and
presenting the paradigm if we're not
penetrating that and the conversation's
not going the way that it should
but it is improving it's just
it more needs to be done all the time
yeah yeah and i feel like um
authenticity i suppose in casting
whether that's a sense of place or a
sense of genuine identity
that's casting a welsh person and a
welsh role um or someone who's
non-binary that is a non-binary actor as
well yeah
yeah i mean that's really important to
us so when we were casting cal in season
three
um
we only saw non-binary actors and now
we're looking forward to trans
characters we're only meeting trans
actors
when it comes to
um casting you know a welsh person for
example we're doing an episode of
something at the moment and it's all
based in wales and the main protagonist
is welsh and at one point
they suggested that we would cast
someone to play well no no no
i think if you want to cast a round
for the other ensemble i understand that
you know look at save the cinema or look
at pride and that's great because you've
got vast ensembles and you do need to
look further afield and i would never
want to pigeonhole welsh people thinking
that they couldn't
do other accents but when it comes to
people from you know marginalized
communities and underrepresented groups
then i think authenticity is the only
way forward
has social media had an impact on how
you cast projects
yeah i mean we we don't really use it
for all briefs but we do use it if we
have a very difficult brief during
lockdown we had to find a
nigerian grandmother in her
70s 80s
um
to play eric's grandmother in sex ed and
we
had no suggestions on twitter at all
not twitter on spotlight at all no one
was a theatrical agencies so we put it
out on twitter we had two suggestions
and
one was amazing perfect
wow really so it does pay to
train
people and she never acted a day in her
life and she was just a superstar and
she loved it i think her daughter had
some sort of tick tock account and
that's how she found it and the word had
spread and we were very lucky that it's
sex ed and it has a following so people
are sharing it left right center
but um yeah it has had a really positive
impact and with our recent sex ed search
for the new trans characters we put it
on twitter and that's been incredible so
if you could give one golden piece of
advice that you would give yourself when
you first started working in the casting
world
maybe a bump in the road that you faced
and something you figured out along the
way what would it be
oh my god
so amazing sorry i know it's a very
existential question
my my favorite thing is
research is key
always go beyond
the sort of natural means always look
beyond i'm forever
and i'm sure my office hate me
i'm always like melissa can we have a
look at you know whether it's like new
up and coming american actors or we try
to cover a lot of different tv shows
like i might watch something that i
might not necessarily watch because it's
not you know a genre i like or you know
i've heard mixed reviews about it but
it's also about watching stuff you see
who is doing what at the moment what
have they just taken who are they
playing opposite what's that type of
role that they've just played okay so
they don't want to play that again in
the next
project or whatever so i think it's just
research you can never do enough whether
it's you know building your databases
whether it's
uh educate yourself about new actors
um yeah watching different tv shows
learning about different directors and
producers
that's my thing is research which is
keen i would never ever want to be that
person that says
i've seen everyone there is to see
i never want to be that person i will
always be like there's more
i'll find more and i might i might
caveat that with i'll find you more but
they will you know they won't be very
good this will be the last one type of
thing but i'll i'll never want to say
this is your lot thank you very much
pick from this
yeah
yeah i love that it's almost like the
search is never over and i know you
mentioned earlier i mean even if someone
isn't right for the specific role that
you're casting then and there they're
always in the back pocket you know has
that happened a lot where you've ended
up reapproaching an actor saying really
sorry didn't get that job that you
wanted but there's something here that
might be perfect for you always and i go
we did it on sex ed i mean not on the
job but the roles that amy lou wood met
for lily and then she booked amy and
then trish who plays ola
met for like three roles and then booked
that
um so it's just finding someone thinking
oh god i love their quality but that's
not quite right and then let's just keep
them in mind they're like oh this one's
just come up great
but you're always you're seeing people
and there's never it's never a wasted
opportunity ever
because they will always stay in the
back of your mind for good of a bad but
they will always stay with you
that's a good point actually is i know
you don't have a name and shame here
obviously but has anyone ever taken you
by surprise we thought oh god no they
really just didn't have it at all and
then you've seen them a couple of months
couple of years later for something
different and they completely knock out
the park
yeah i mean some people do just develop
and
and grow and
just improve at it which of course you
do if you're doing it all the time you
do practice and you get better and i
suppose there's a time where you'll see
someone you think oh maybe that wasn't
quite what i was looking for but it
depends
it depends how how bad it was or how
off-piste it was and whether that was a
decision
or whether that was them you know not
taking your direction
depending sort of
what setting that was in but
yeah there's definitely been times where
you've seen people
when time has gone on and they've
just eased into it or maybe they've
become more comfortable with the way
that they act and
maybe they don't want it as much and
that really helps as well when you relax
a little bit more you don't put so much
pressure on yourself
what's the most rewarding thing
about your job flooded
i think got like i suppose it's giving
them the opportunity and then it
happening like um we love to do the
calls
the job is laws and the reaction is
brilliant like we did it last week for
this guy that came in probably about
five times for a series
and the agent cried and then she called
us back and she said he's just cried and
he's been waiting for this opportunity
we're like we know
and it's so lovely just to be able to
offer that and i suppose it's you know
the crux of it is you're giving someone
maybe some financial stability
and then on the flip side it's like you
know they're getting to do the job of
their dreams and they got the role they
want
but yeah i think that's the most
rewarding part of it